oh i don't know if i should pick up this
next call who is this
it's apples and he wants to talk about
ronnie and here we go howard check that
instagram he put the some of the
christmas decorations made the trip to
vegas
his neighbors knew exactly which one he
was
it's like oh i've got the big globe and
the dragon was where was the dragon
there's no dragon dude so you don't even
know what you're talking about you're
such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
what did you put on the lawn for
decorations out in vegas
we had put some lights up and a couple
of little blow up things that was it
what were they not the drag
no there's no dragon there was he's full
of [ __ ] there was all right
i
correctly
the dragon i like the dragon yeah you're
right dragon was your signature dude why
don't you come clean about your life
what let's hear about your life a little
bit come on
that's all you need to [ __ ] do is sit
there and laugh like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
what did you have on your lawn that's
what i don't know your life what do you
know what did he have on his lawn
who cares what he has no no i care i
want to know what he have
did you have anything on your lawn
no i didn't decorate it
no anyways
[ __ ] morning [ __ ]
dude ronnie told the guys there wasn't
room for his blow up dragon on the lawn
so it wasn't that he didn't want to put
it out there it just wasn't room for my
correct run am i saying anything out of
school this place where i was going to
put it up
was being
uh used for construction so okay it was
so there wasn't room
yes but your neighbors are thrilled
ronnie had a giant blow up snow globe on
his lawn a blow-up penguin
what's the other thing there i can't
even tell it's a car it's from the car
from cars
from the movie cars all right there you
look at that go to him oh he's a [ __ ]
dude cars is a kid's movie right so but
it's a movie you enjoy is that the idea
no i just like the [ __ ] car it was
cool okay all right you know in cars
they are talking cars
right exactly do you like talking rodney
[Laughter]
i only pray that my 75 year old neighbor
would uh have a cartoon blow up doll on
his front yard
uh because it seems to make the prices
around sore my neighbors had that [ __ ]
on their lawn also okay all right you
found the perfect neighborhood
right exactly i fit right in